yeah you've had a crazy life huh Paris
and then obviously before you did uh you
were editing you did um softcore uh porn
is in the chest piece obviously this is
my favorite story you've ever told me
you have to tell gant's story we're
we're far off in the episode now where
it's fine yeah so uh at the beginning I
was picking up every job like that I
could cuz I I it was so hard to do
anything as an editor like I I would say
I'm like the second wave of editors
where pretty much editing for YouTubers
didn't exist back then so it was like
really hard to find one and I was using
this site called upwork which was like a
decent back then but now it's really
[__] cuz you have to pay for every
review you send in back then I used to
send in like 60 reviews every single day
or something like that uh and one of the
jobs I got was like oh uh do you want to
edit Vlogs and I'm like all right cool
uh and I started editing it I'm like
yeah that's a bit um that this is a bit
weird and I guess I edited it well
enough that he he was like um well do
you want to do more stuff and I was like
okay what was this initial Vlog what
was [__] I can't remember it was
something about um pleasuring
women so I was like I I was kind of
picking up like all right there's a guy
talking about it yeah like how to
pleasure women or something like that
but but I think there was a bit more
logishetty do you want to edit more like
more raunchier stuff I'm like all right
you know sure whatever pays the bills
man yeah exactly and yeah just softcore
porn is it what is softcore porn what do
that involv like just no penetration
like kissing uh well he had an Nish of
course you have an nishe which is uh
Yoni massage okay which is U [__]
massage so he would he would be like
expertise cats right like cat massage
yeah it would be him doing it for around
2 to 3 hours what okay two it would go
up to five I think no and uh actually it
was a nice precursor to trash taste
cuz now there are three [__] on the
screen cuz he he had uh like four to
five camera setup okay and uh G you say
you're a perfectionist yeah but he was
an actual perfectionist it would be like
2 to three hour video like end result
where it had to be like the cuts had to
be frame perfect it would if it would be
like one frame off it would be like on
me like I had to change it and uh every
Friday we would get in calls uh that
would last like four to 6 hours of just
trying going through the edits like oh
the intro that's like not that good or
have to change that that's little T and
every single cut had to be framed
perfect there's like um when I started
it was like two way fors of uh
information how to cut it like in the
beginning it would be like YouTubers do
now which would be like fastpaced like
intro that was like 7 years ago at this
point and then it would be like a music
video
section what of like getting into it
undressing like what the heck some stuff
and then it would be like slowly getting
into the main section of like actually
doing it which was um there's also rules
behind it like uh in the beginning it
would be Cuts Like every 10 SEC uh
seconds if you're like half an hour in
it could be like up to 30 seconds a cut
it can't be over 30 seconds and the C
has to be at the apex of the
movement apex of the movement why is he
talking like a movie director it was it
was actually L intense Jesus but yeah he
lasted for like 2 years did he play well
uh okay and then he was like okay you
know I'm I'm paying you too much I'm
going to replace you with two cheap uh
people
instead and you know that's when we gave
you the call for trash taste right no
okay so I used to like I I like to go
back and like check on like PE previous
employeers like how they're doing yeah
for the next year he posted nothing and
then approached me and was like all
right I'm going to offer you double the
price you paid I'm like I guess those
two editors W that good and I'm like was
he making a lot of money from this or I
assume so wow cuz it's poing and I was
like I I don't know how much money is in
there I was like uh no I want to get
paid three times as much cuz I'm like no
yeah and he was like No And I was like
yeah and he was like okay and then you
went back you got back in it yeah how
many years ago was this uh originally
like 5 years ago I ate it for 2 years
then it was like a break of one year and
then for another two years and it was
even more intense cuz at the end I I
gave up I was like okay I can't do it
I'm quitting cuz it was so intense like
uh the work sessions was so huge it was
literally like uh 20 hours a week that
was half that was a part-time job next
to like six YouTubers I also edited for
wait were you doing this while you were
editing for me
yeah and
wow wow I didn't know this and uh I
think yeah when I quit uh I I gave in
like my two months notice yeah which I
figured out I found out you don't have
to give two months notice yeah you can
just leave yeah I didn't know that I was
like I I don't want to be a dick like
leaving me I mean it's polite to give
it's polite but usually it's one month
notice yeah a lot a lot of contract one
month so we started writing up like what
to give to the next person like they had
to do the same thing cuz to get every
like video done it wasn't just the main
video it was also like different
websites different time stamps different
every so it was kind of like gaming the
system cuz the thumbnails in those sites
were autogenerated based on what it
picks up at those time like seconds like
frames but he had a system where he knew
if the videos were this long it would
generate these frames so like for every
website it had to be a different length
video and so he planned out like where
exactly the frames would be oh my God
and it was like four different Google
Sheets to actually get like like one
video done and when we tried to get like
new people in to like replace me I think
the end result for the Google docs on
how you edit a video was 40
pages how do you write 40 pages it was
so int that's why I want to finish cuz
it wasn't fun it wasn't editing it was
literal job like you had to do
everything to as well yeah and it was
four years and even at the end of four
years I still felt like I couldn't do it
like how he wanted to yeah like I was
you wer perfect enough for him yeah I
was so imperfect it was so annoying to
me as well cuz I like couldn't so how
many hours of this cat massaging did you
have to sit through like in total yeah
per session you must be so desensitized
you must be so desensitized to it I
think at then he was my 500s I don't
know
Christ that's so funny holy [__] oh my
Lord and now he's on trash T so honestly
it was a bit sketchy cuz it was a huge
chunk of Revenue but when you were like
trash tasted I was like okay this is a
good chance like move
past to move
past I could use all my skills correctly
get some free time you know but that was
the last thing that also like really
burned me out like in terms of editing
well you get yeah that's yeah let me ask
you this question how do you avoid
burnout in your in your uh like the way
you things the way you do things I don't
I it's either I I just don't like I
either got burnt out 6 years ago or I
don't
I don't know where you I just don't get
burnout do you just not recognize the
burnout and you just kind of push
through it all I think I'm desensitized
to burnout or I just take jobs that like
don't burn me out cuz like there's so
much work that I have to do that anytime
I get like tired of one job I like
switch over to oh I'm make thumbnails
now or I'm going to do clips now I'm
going to go back to the first job I'm
going to do like a different different
thing so I guess having like a variation
of different jobs is like a good way
right yeah yeah cuz burnout is just
suboptimal performance you [__] you're
right I got to start taking my vitamins
just like a skill issue at the end of
the day you know not managing Rabbit
Hole to go down the moment I feel burned
out I just pop open that medicine box
I'm good to go one thing you also told
me that I just didn't appreciate cuz I'm
like man we're so fortunate have to do
this you did uh in in Estonia you to do
uh mandatory Service as well yeah so you
to do like eight months of military time
right yeah oh really After High School I
went into it like straight away because
I didn't want to do it later because if
they call you like five years on Down
the Line when you're doing [__] yeah
yeah it really sucks so I had to I went
there like uh voluntarily they were like
no you're too skinny come back in half a
year like no no no let's do two month uh
weeks and they were like all right one
month so I went back and thankfully got
it cuz otherwise it would have gone like
another year yeah yeah and yeah then I
got in and what if you were too skinny
the entire time could they just could
they just never ask you to serve yeah
but I don't think I would have been cuz
before that I had like some sort of a
disease that lasted for a month that
couldn't eat so I lost 10 kg in weight
damn okay wow so I was like yeah I can
easily pack that on like get me in two
weeks and I'll do
it what did you do for those two weeks
just [__] go to town I just ate
normally cuz I I ate normally for like a
month I could only eat once a day and it
was like one pudding otherwise it would
have been too painful right oh my God
what disease is that I think I had I'm
not sure if it was mono like like my uh
the the glands yeah that's mono right
those like really went insanely huge and
got like infected so I had to take like
not Paras like insane painkillers that
you can take once a day and then even
then I could just eat pudding otherwise
it's like too much JS Christ is there
any part of your life that you can you
still think you can optimize find time
what's next what's next for M what's
next for mud it's just well it's not
like huge optimization movements it's
just like slow like steady
like you get a new client you're like
all right how can I got to ask what's
what's an average day look like for you
wake up uh see around 9:00 a.m. nice oh
yeah see what you guys have written like
uh the fires I have to take out cuz
usually when I wake up in the morning
it's around like noon or night time for
you and then I'm like oh my God there's
like 10 things that popped up I got to
do ads I got to do that so the first two
3 hours of just doing like origin stuff
yeah then I eat then I do um either gym
or U running cardio and then I do like
the stuff that I had to do that day like
10 20 items I usually put in my to-do
list yeah that's a
lot that comes you make it sound easy
that comes after the gym and everything
like that doing 10 20 things in a day or
I guess more realistically the second
half of the day it's quite a bit uh and
then it's like 2:00 a.m. and I go to bed
do you ever do you ever get cuz like
I've had you know weeks when I've been
super super productive and all it takes
is like one little slip off to take you
off your like schedule and routine and
then everything like just crumbles do do
you ever get that all or oh yeah it does
happen like after vacations and stuff no
well no you work on
vacations what no okay I I get it I
never fall out of working the only thing
I fall out of is just like taking care
of myself diet or gym I'll slack and
I'll be like okay I'll slack another day
it's like out of 5 years or six years of
doing this I think Japan was the first
time like this is the most have taken
off or like away from my uh home like
ever this is 2 weeks usually it's like 3
days or 3 four days yeah yeah so I mean
even here like every day four five hours
of work oh my God please please get
please have a vacation please have a day
where you do nothing a day you just try
why do you refuse awful I did the white
room stream I didn't feel that great
doing like that at all I did nothing
fors [__] vacation you actually doing
stuff m i I didn't do anything I took 12
hours off it wasn't that fun I a white
room what do you expect I took 12 hours
off here's what happened guys Chris be
like I took 36 years off of my life I
saw I saw I saw a [__] screenshot and
it was like from Tik Tok and it was a
guy going like and it was like
unemployed people when they have to eat
breakfast and play video games all
day that's like Ruden
no just try it you can you can turn into
a YouTube video If you I tried it I
don't like it I took a day off level
impossible it's horrible
now I get the Jitters I'm like [__] I
got to edit man [__] give it to me
fair enough where is the timeline godamn
it uh any advice you might have uh
editors yeah or future editors no like
if you don't like it
quit I mean I think that's great advice
that's real ADV that's just great life
advice in general do you do you like
editing or do you want to get lots of
YouTube views which is
it tell them tell them how it is B